THANK YOU MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND
WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- GOOD AFTERNOON
ARMS A COUPLE WORDS BEFOREHAND
THAT ARE- THIS HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS WITNESS WILL BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON OR BY PHONE
THE NUMBER TO CALL IS
877-692-8957 ONCE AGAIN EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS
CODE WILL BE ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO
ONE ONE ZERO ZERO AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO
ONE ONE ZERO ZERO THIS NUMBER
COULD BE FOUND THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE ALSO DISPLAYED ON YOUR
SCREENS. AFTER THOSE CALLING IN
PLEASE ME TO SOLVE A WIRE IN THE
QUEUE TO MULLIN ELIMINATE ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE EACH BURKE
EACH- BILL WILL BE HEARD TO DATE
THEY'LL BE OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION DOES
REMAIN WITNESSES EACH WILL
RECEIVE TWO MINUTES- AND I'LL
JUST TO BE FAIR I'LL REMIND
EVERYONE THE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING IT WILL BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL
BE ALTERNATED. WHEN IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN ON
MEET YOURSELF IN ORDER TO SPEAK
PLEASE BE BRIEF LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO ONLY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
A SERGEANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I STILL DON'T
FEEL QUORUM I FEEL CONTINUES A
SUBCOMMITTEE- THEN THE ALSO
ANNOUNCEMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA PUT IT WILL BE SUBSTITUTED
FOR SOME A MEMBER COOLEY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING- THEY'LL BE A
CONSENT COUNTERSUED WE CALL A
QUORUM ALL ASK FOR A FIRST AND A
SECOND. I SEEING ONE AUTHOR HERE
. YOU ARE- YOU MAY PRESENT TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CAR. BUT WE ARE SUB WE'RE
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE DO BUT-
YEAH. INDICATION IF SUPPORTERS
THIS IS NOTED.
AREA ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER
BERMAN- THANK YOU CHAIR SANTIAGO
AND MEMBERS- BEFORE ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
STAFF WORKING IN MY OFFICE NOT
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR PERMIT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROLLED ISSUE
CANNABIS. CATERING LICENSES TO
ALLOW LICENSEES TO SERVE
CANNABIS OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS A
PRIVATE EVENTS. DESPITE
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION BECOMING AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE FOR VISITORS AND
RESIDENTS ALIKE. THE STATE IS
YET TO REGULATE CANNABIS
CATERING AND HOTELS AND
THROUGHOUT THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CANNABIS
RETAILERS CAN BE ISSUED STATE
TEMPORARY EVENT LICENSES THAT
ALLOW FOR ON SITE CANNABIS SALES
CONSUMPTION WITHIN WITHIN A
LIMITED SET OF VENUES. AND UNDER
SPECIFIC RESTRICTIONS BY THE
STATE. HOWEVER THESE LICENSES DO
NOT CURRENTLY COVER SITUATIONS
IN WHICH AN EVENT HOST PRE PAYS
FOR CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO BE PROVIDED FREE OF
CHARGE EVENT GAS. I BY CREATING
THESE HEARING LICENSES AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR WILL CREATE A
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT TO HELP
INSURE THERE'S GREATER SAFETY
AND OVERSIGHT OF CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION AT GATHERINGS SUCH
AS WELL WEDDINGS AND WELLNESS
RETREATS. HERE TO TESTIFY
SUPPORTERS MARVIN PINEDA ON
BEHALF THE UNITED CANNABIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M WAS CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
PMB HAVE WITH A NECK HAS BEEN
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I REPRESENTING RETAILERS IN LONG
BEACH LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO.
A COACHELLA RETEST THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
THE RETAIL LICENSE CURRENTLY.
THIS EVENTS ARE TAKING PLACE
WITH NO REGULATION. WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS THAT 75% OF THE
MARKET RIGHT NOW IS ILLICIT. SO
INDIVIDUALS ARE PURCHASING BY
BALK AND TAKING. THE CANISTER
THIS EVENT WHICH IS UNTESTED
UNREGULATED AND UNTAXED SO THIS
PROVIDES STAFF FRAMEWORK. THE
BILL. RESPECTS PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR IN THAT IT REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTION APPROVAL I TO
RESPECT THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
ARE CURRENTLY WE SEEN THE
PEIPING PRICES IN THE PAST WHERE
THEY CAME FROM UNTESTED
UNREGULATED PRODUCTS. IDEAS WILL
BE ANOTHER SOURCE FOR RETAILERS
TO GET THE PRODUCT OUT INTO THE
MARKET AND AS WE HAVE MORE.
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA IN URBAN
AREAS I THIS WILL BE A TOOL TO
PRY CANNABIS AT THIS EVENT AND-
YEAH I INTENT IS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS EVENTS ARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TWENTY ONE YEARS AND
OLDER. I'LL WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
NO ADDITIONAL WOULDN'T TAKE YOU
ANY MAIN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. I AM HEARING AND HEARING NONE
FALL JUST CONTINUE TO MOVE A
PUBLIC COMMENTS OF SUPPORT- ON
THE PHONE OR PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. WHEN I CAN'T FOR
THOSE PARTICIPANTS ON THE PHONE
TO HEAR IN FAVOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NOT HEARING ANY
AND I CAN BE CORRECTED DOWN THE
LINE JUST TO MOVE THE MEETING
I'M GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- YES MISTER
COOPER. IT IS A QUESTION THAT I
KNOW SAYS THAT NO KIDS ARE
NOBODY UNDER TWENTY ONE BUT
WEDDINGS AND STUFF I MEAN. SO
IT'S KNOWN OR TWENTY ONE
CORRECT. THAT THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT A
FORMALIZED YOU THE WEDDING
PEOPLE WE KIDS AND STUFF THINGS
LIKE THAT IT'S- YOU KNOW THE
FORTUNATE. ASPECT ON THAT WE SEE
A LOT OF KIDS GOOD OLD CANNABIS
LATELY SO HOW DO WE- ARE WE SURE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN WITH THE-
BACKDROP ON THAT THIS REGIONAL
QUESTION- OUR OFFICE EXCEPT
AMENDMENTS AND BMP COMMITTEE
THATALIGN THIS BILL WITH.
EXISTING LAWS RELATED TO ALCOHOL
CATERING CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
LOUNGES. ONE OF THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT RESTRICT UNDERAGE
CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS. AND
PROVIDE THAT ALL CONSUMPTION
PRIVATE AND SHOULD BE SEPARATE.
AND HIDDEN FROM UNDERAGE GASES
BUILD REQUIRE. CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION INDICATOR PRIVATE
EVENT OCCUR IN A RESTRICTED
AREA. THE COMPLIES THE SAME AGE
RESTRICTIONS AS CONSUMPTION
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES AND LICENSE
TEMPORARY EVENTS- AND FOR THE
MORE BY CREATING THIS LICENSE BE
SURE THAT. THAT THAT THERE CAN
BE A CATER PRESENT A CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ARE LIKE CLEARLY
LABELED AS CANNABIS. AND THE
DOSAGE INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
NO MISTAKING THE PRODUCT- THIS
CREATES A SAFER ENVIRONMENT IS
MUCH MORE REGULATORS OPPOSE WHAT
IS CURRENTLY HAPPENING WHERE
FOLKS ARE. BRING IN THEIR OWN
PRODUCTS NO OVERSIGHT OR SAFETY
MEASURES WHATSOEVER BUT- THE
FIRST PORTION OF THE ANSWERED
WHAT MAKES IT VERY CLEAR THAT
IT'S SEPARATED. OUT IN A
RESTRICTED AREA. OKAY THANK YOU
I'M I'M A STOP THE SERVER ONE
SECOND JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE A
CORPSMAN I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND WE CAN GET TO. ON THE QUORUM
SANTIAGO HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN BRIAN IF HI AND BIGELOW.
COOPER DOLLY DALY HERE DAVIES
THERE GARCIA. GIPSON JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY LOW. MATHIS YOUR
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS RIVAS RUBIO.
SALAS SMITH. ONE WELCOME AND
THANK YOU TO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GOT A CORPUS ABOLITION
OF THAT MYSTERIOUS THANK YOU- IF
I COULD JUST PIGGYBACK OFF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CLIPPERS-
QUESTION OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU HAVE
A BAR YOU'VE GOT A BARTENDER
THERE IS TO GET SOMEONE ACTUALLY
HANDING YOU THE PRODUCT OF
CHECKING FOR ID'S WOULD THAT BE
THE SAME THEN IF YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A SEPARATE ROOM WITH ANY-
ANY FOOD PRODUCTS WITH CATERING
SOMEONE WOULD WALK UP AND
ACTUALLY ASK FOR IDEAS- WOULD
USE AND WOULD DO IT WOULD BE IT
WOULD. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO
YOU EVEN MORE RESTRICTIVE IN
THAT IF YOU GO TO A WEDDING
USUALLY OPEN BARS ARE KIND OF
EVERYWHERE IN THIS CASE WOULD
ACTUALLY NOT ONLY OF HAVE
SOMEONE THAT WOULD HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT SOMEONE'S OF AGE BUT
IT WOULD BE A SEPARATE- A
SEPARATE RESTRICTED AREA OF THE
COMPLIES WITH THOSE A MAJOR
SECTIONS OF IT AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR THE REASON WE DID THAT
THAT THE REASON WE- ACCEPTED
MOVES FORTH REPORT REGULATION
WHEN NONE EXISTS BECAUSE CURLY
RIGHT NOW PEOPLE WHO NOT ONLY
TAUGHT REGULATORS NO WAIT A-
MODERATE THIS WILL PUT IN STRONG
RULES AND FRAMEWORK AROUND IT SO
THAT THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS IS
ALREADY HAPPENING SO HE'S DOING
IS PUTTING A FRAMEWORK
REGULATION AND THOSE CONCERNS I
SHOULD BE ADDRESSES CITED A BIT
BUT I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF A LOT
OF CONFUSION ABOUT THIS BILL
VERY EARLY ON IT ISN'T THAT HE'S
WANTING TO SAY HEY LET'S
EVERYBODY GO DO IT IT'S EXISTING
LET'S PUT A FRAMEWORK AROUND IT-
NOW I WAS. ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NOT ENOUGH I COULD DROP
MISTER COOPER. DID YOU HAVE
ANYTHING FURTHER. NOW WITH
ADVISERS A COUPLE P. ON THE
PHONE FOR I WANTED TO MOVE IT
QUICKER IF WE CAN GO. THEM
UNLESS THERE MAY. OP WE- ARE.
MAKE NAME OR- OF POSITIONALLY.
THE DISCOVERY AND FIRST LITTLE
LINE. ENDEAVOR LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY TWENTY
ONE LITTLE GO HEAD. ONE OF THE
THREE GROUND WITH SOCIAL EQUITY
RALLY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION OF
LOS ANGELES AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK. NEXT WILL TO LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
HELLO. MY NAME IS GERRY KYLO I
AM A BOARD CHAIR OF THAT CANNOT
THE THIRD SHE- WE ARE UPON BELL
AND THE ATHLETES I BOUGHT THE.
NIKOLAI NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TRAVIS ON THE OF
THIS FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ALLIANCE HERE TO
INDICATE OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT LITTLE LINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A UPSET
THOUGH UNITED CANNABIS BIGGEST
LOCATION AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ADAM
HEJAZI I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WE HAD AN
INTENT TO DO A FIRST IN THE
SECOND EARLIER NEEDED TO RECEIVE
THEM NOW I CAN'T REMEMBER THAT.
MISTER LOW AND- MR DAILY. YES IN
IT BUT THIS IS JUST A QUESTION
WILL BE REQUIRED TO CONSUME
CANNABIS IN THAT RESTRICTED AREA
OR THE CONNECTICUT WITH MINGLE.
OUT THE- IN THAT AREA. YEAH IT'S
SIMILAR TO- OTHER TYPE ABOUT WE
ARE BASING PATTERN AND FRANKLY
REALLY APPRECIATE BOTH THE BNP
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THIS
COMMITTEE A CONSULTANTS FOR
CHEAPER FOR MAKING A LANGUAGE
MUCH MORE CLEAR BUT IT REQUIRED
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION ALLOCATOR
PRIVATE EVENT TO OCCUR IN A
RESTRICTED AREA THE COMPLIES THE
SAME AGE RESTRICTIONS OF
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES A LICENSE
TEMPORARY EVENTS SO WE'RE
ALIGNING IT WITH OTHER. TYPES OF
SIMILAR TYPE CONTENT BUT IT DOES
HAVE TO BE CONSUMED IN THAT
AREA. BUT WHAT WHAT I WONDER IS
FOR INSTANCE IF YOU HAVE IT AN
INDOOR AREA WHERE THEY'RE DOING
IT. AND THEN THEY'RE SELLING-
FLOWER- YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL
CANNABIS ITSELF. AND THEY'VE SB
SMOKED. BECAUSE HE CANCELED
INDOORS. HOW'S THAT DONE YOU
HAVE TO SEPARATE THE SMOKING
AREA. THE AREA WHERE IT'S GIVEN
TO THE- INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
HOW DO YOU. RECONCILE THAT WHAT
THE RESTRICTED AREA. REGARDLESS
THE SOFT COMPLY WITH OUR INDOOR
SMOKING WILL ALSO THEY HAVE AN
OUTDOOR AREA THAT THEY CAN
CREATE INTEREST ACTED AREA.
THAT'S FINE IT IS INDOORS OR TO
HAVE TO BE EMBEDDABLE OR OTHERS
OTHER FORM OTHER THAN SMOKE.
SURE SUCH I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IS NOT WHERE. THEY'RE
THEY'RE SERVED INDOORS. AND THEN
OKAY GOT SMOKELESS. IN THE
OUTDOORS BUT IS NOT MONITORED
YEAH THAT COULD THAT COULD
HAPPEN TO I MEAN COULD THEY
COULD DESIGNATE AREA. FOR
SMOKING BUT IS NOT MONITORED AND
SO I THINK WE NEED TO. IT I
WOULD SUGGEST TO HAVE SOMEONE IN
THAT AREA TO MONITOR IT. THE
BOTH AREAS THE SENATE. WELL I.
IF I IF I COULD MISS RICHARD
IDEAS THAT IF IT'S- IF THEY HAVE
AN OUTDOOR AREA THAT IS THE WAS
THE RESTRICTED AREA IT WOULD
HAVE TO BE CONSUMED IN THAT
AREA- IF IT'S AN INDOOR AREA IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE EDIBLE OR
SOMETIME BEFORE THE DOESN'T HAVE
SMOKE- BUT TO YOUR POINT YOU
KNOW IT IT JUST LIKE ANY OTHER.
SMOKING OR SMOKING LAWS WILL
HAVE TO BE ABIDED BY IN THIS
CASE. FOR THIS CONSUMPTION AT AN
EVENT WOULD HAVE TO HAPPEN IN A
RESTRICTED AREA. IF THERE IS NOT
AN OUTDOOR RESTRICTED AREA THEN
IT WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED. THE
SMOKE. THE SMOKING OF THE FORM
OF- CONSUMPTION. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT RECOMMENDING ANY
MINUTES BUT MAYBE SOMETHING THAT
THE THAT THE AUTHOR WANTS TO
CONSIDER DOWN THE LINES TO MAKE
IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THAT
DOESN'T CONTINUE TO. POP UP AS
YOU MOVE THE BILL ALONG THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS MISTER
COOPER. WITH A FIRST AND A
SECOND OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. BUT NO I THINK THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AS WELL
AS THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE OF
HELP TO CLARIFY. THE BETTER
BILL- AND SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK TO. READ WHENEVER
CLARIFICATIONS THAT OBSERVER
COOPER DAVIES EITHER HAVE HAPPY. TO TAKE THEM AS REPORT AS
WELL. A MAN TAXIS CULTURAL. AB
EIGHT FOUR THE MOST IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE CA ON A
PER SOMETHING I BIG.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN BRIAN. BE
ABLE TO WALK. COOPER DOLLY. DALY
DAVIES. GARCIA. GIPSON JONES
SAWYER I INNOVEST BE ADDED ON AS
A CO AUTHOR. LACKEY LOW MATHIS.
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS. RIVAS RUBIO.
SALAS SMITH. WILL BE THE BILL
OPEN THANK YOU AND THEN I WOULD
NEED THE FIRST AND SECOND- FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IT UP WE
HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE **** IN A
MOVING TO APPRECIATE THAT AND-
THOSE ARE AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
NINE. AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY ONE ALL OF A
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BILLS- MEDICARE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN
I BRIAN BRIAN I BIGELOW BIGELOW
IVF WOULD WANNA. COOPER COOPER
AYE DOLLY DOLLY I DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES AYE GARCIA. GARCIA
AYE GIPSON JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW LOW
AYE MATHIS MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I'D ALMOST. RAMOS IT
OF US RIVERSIDE RUBIO. SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I. THE BILL
OPEN- MR LOW IF YOU'D BE KIND
ENOUGH TO PRESENT- AB. SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE. THE FIRST MINISTER
RIGHT. I REMEMBER RIVAS- BY MR
BERMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COLLEAGUES AN EXPEDITIOUS MANNER
THIS IS A SOMEBODY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE TRANSGENDER DAY
OF REMEMBRANCE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH ME TODAY IS
ALEXIS SANCHEZ WITH THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER
AS WELL AS LEARN POLITO FROM THE
GENDER HEALTH CENTER. HE ALSO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER L<c.cyan>G YOU MAY BEGIN TWO</c>
MINUTES EACH TO YOUR MAIN
SORRY ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALEXIS SANCHEZ I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
TRAINING FOR THE SACRAMENTO LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY WHAT. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN TRACKED A RECORD
NUMBER OF VIOLENT FATAL
INCIDENCES ARE AGAINST
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE. WITH FIFTY
FATALITIES TRACKED IN THE U. S.
ALONE THIS IS A NUMBER THAT'S
MUCH HIGHER WORLDWIDE.
TRANSGENDER DAY OF REMEMBRANCE
SEEKS TO HIGHLIGHT THE LOSSES WE
FACE DUE TO ANTI TRANSGENDER
BIGOTRY AND VIOLENCE. STATE
RECOGNITION CREATES A SPACE
WHERE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE LIVING
IN RURAL AREAS WHERE DON'T WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ORGANIZE TRANSGENDER DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE EVENTS STILL HAVE
THEIR GRIEF RECOGNIZED BY THE
STATE. IT ALSO SENDS A MESSAGE
TO TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING CALIFORNIANS THAT
THEY LIVE IN A STATE THAT VALUES
THEIR LIVES AT A TIME WHEN OTHER
STATES ARE WORKING TO FURTHER
MARGINALIZE THEM VIA ANTI TRANS
LOTS. AT THE STATE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO CENTER THE NEEDS OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE HIGH INCIDENCE
OF ANTI TRANSGENDER VIOLENCE IF
WE'RE EVER GOING TO IRAQI
TRANSPHOBIA. I WILL SAVE MYSELF
AS A TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUAL AND
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE THESE
EVENTS. AND CARRY A LOT OF
WEIGHT FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR
US AS INDIVIDUALS AS WELL IN
TWENTY TWENTY I LOST A VERY DEAR
FRIEND TO ANTI TRANSGENDER
VIOLENCE AND SOMEONE WHO'S
BRUTALLY ASSAULTED. AND THAT.
THESE EVENTS FOR TRANSGENDER DAY
OF REMEMBRANCE GIVE OUR
COMMUNITY A SPACE TO REALLY
CREATE AND MAKES HER THAT OUR
VOICES. THAT WERE HELD BY OUR
COMMUNITY I OFTENTIMES WHEN THE
WORLD OUTSIDE CAN BE VERY VERY
CRUEL TO US SO I'M AGAIN I JUST
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ANOTHER WITNESS MISSILE. I'VE
RAPS ON THE LINE YEAH LET'S
LET'S CHECK THE LINE MISTER-
THEIR MEMBERS MR MAT AMOUNT A
MONITOR PLEASE. HELLO CAN YOU
ALL HEAR ME. YES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBER MY NAME IS MARKLEEVILLE
COEXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CO
DIRECTOR ADVOCATE APARTMENT HERE
AT THE CENTRE HEALTH CENTER IN
SACRAMENTO HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE AB SEVENTY
FORTY ONE AS MANY AS ONE OF MANY
CRITICAL STEPS NEEDED CORRECTION
CENTER COMMUNITY. MY TWENTY ONE
WITH THE HIGHEST YEAR IN DEATH
RATES FOR TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AND
EACH YEAR BACK THAT NUMBER
GROWS. EVERY YEAR WE NEED MORE
MORE TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS GET
INTO VIOLENCE AND HARM
PERPETUATED BY THE LACK OF
AWARENESS VISIBILITY EDUCATION.
IN MOST OF OUR UNDERSTANDING. IT
IS MORE THAN JUST THE BILL THIS
IS ONE OF MANY LIFESAVING
MOVEMENTS AND CHANGES NEED FOR
OUR COMMUNITY IN A CARIBBEAN.
AND MANY MORE I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- IS
THERE ANY MAIN OPPOSITIONS ANY
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES. RIGHT
HEARING SEEING NONE- WE'RE GOING
TO GO PUBLIC COMMENTS ANY
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM WE'LL BEGIN WITH SUPPORT.
CNN I'LL GO ON TO OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PHONES-
MISTER MODERATOR. AND IF THEY'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO BECAUSE TIME. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER MISTER BRIAN I DON'T
KNOW IF I MISS SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT'S ONE THING OFFERING THIS
BILL FORD IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
CO OTHERS A MATTER JOIN. MISTER
COOPER PLEASE I WANNA THANK
GOODNESS FOR COMING AND SPEAKING
I APPRECIATE YOU- THE CRIMES
GETS A TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY-
I'M GONNA- EXPONENTIALLY OVER
TIME IN THE SAD PART ABOUT IT IS
A CRIME CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
CONSIDERED VIOLENT CRIMES YOU
COMMIT A CRIME THE RELEASED
EARLY SO WE JUST RALLIED THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY AROUND IT
IN INDEFINITELY GIVE THIS LAW
CHANGE BECAUSE THIS IS NOT FAIR.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
WITH US MR BERMAN JUST ONE THING
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FORD THANK THE
WITNESS FOR COMING IN TESTIFYING
TODAY WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AS WELL THANK YOU.
MR PRESIDENT MISS YOU RAISING
YOUR HAND APOLOGIZE IF I DID
APOLOGIZE- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF YOUR
SHOPPING CART THERE'S- YEAH
MISTER GIBSON SORRY. LET ME ADD
MY VOICE TO THE CHORUS PLEASE
ADD ME AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
BILL AS WELL AS- GOOD THOUGHTFUL
BILL I READ IT REVIEWED IT. AND
ONE DAY MY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE- TO FIND-AGAIN CALLED
IT PRESENTED ANOTHER COMMITTEES
I GOT DISTRACTED FOR SECOND I
APOLOGIZE BUT STILL IT WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE. A COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR DEEP EMPATHY
AND GRACE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
LOVE IN HELPING TO ROUTE REFLECT
THE MEMORIES OF THE LIVES LOST
FOR. A VULNERABLE COMMUNITY AND
WE STAND FIRM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF ALL INDIVIDUAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MASSACRED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND MAY I HAVE MISTER BIGELOW
CHAIR WHILE I GO PRESENTED.
LET'S LET ME DO THIS LET ME.
JUST CALL THE ROLL INCIDENT-
MISTER BILL WOULD YOU KINDLY
OPEN UP THE ROLL CALL ON MR US
CAR WAS BUILT RIGHT AFTER THAT.
THANK YOU. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
SANTIAGO. YEAH YES SANTIAGO AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I AGUIAR-CURRY
. BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN RYAN I
BE A GOOD ONE. COOPER COOPER AYE
DALI DALI I DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES. AB YEAH I'LL BRING UP
THE- GARCIA. GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW I LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I'D ALMOST RAMOS I'D
RIVAS. RIVERSIDE RUBIO. SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I. YOU HAVE
SEVENTEEN NUMBER OF VOTES-
TECHNICALLY THE BILL IS OUT BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO BOB
WELL DONE IF YOU DON'T MIND
COULD WE OPEN- IF THE VOTE. YOUR
SYSTEM ABOUT MR IN ITEM THREE
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY. MISTER
KALRA THIS IS MR CALLERS BILL HE
PRESENTED FOR THOSE THAT WERE
ABSENT AND WE HEARD TESTIMONY-
WITH A QUORUM IS PRESENT SO THIS
WILL BE ON AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR. COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
KALRA AGUIAR-CURRY. THE UP WOULD
WANT. GIPSON GIPSON AYE LACKEY.
RIVAS THE BUS I RUBIO. SALAS.
SALAS NO. OKAY SAME STORY THERE
HAS ENOUGH VOTES ON TO GET OUT
BUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE REMAINING ABSENT MEMBERS
WERE COMING HERE FROM OTHER
COMMITTEES NOW WE'LL MOVE ON MR
LOW YOU HAVE THE FLOOR WITH AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX. YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND MR LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE SOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATE
CONSIDERATION OF THAT BIPARTISAN
MEASURE TO RECOGNIZE LUNAR NEW
YEAR IS A HOLIDAY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
THAT BREAD DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. SO I'M NOT. I'M CAN
WE GO TO THE OPERATOR LET ME GO
TO THE OTHER FLOOR HERE ANYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE WISHING TO
ADDRESS THIS- MEASURE. THING NO
ONE OUGHT TO THE OPERATOR COULD
YOU SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
PHONE THAT WISHES TO ADDRESSES
AND THE SUPPORT POSITION. AND IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN UP LINE TWENTY FIVE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS
MELANIE MARLA SOMETHING HAPPENED
A GREEN LINE INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO NO STOOD UP
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE AT WHICH IS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
MAJOR. SAYING NINE GO TO THE
OPERATOR COULD YOU SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO LINE'S QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR. THIS BILL. SEEING
NO ONE RALLIED TO THE CALL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU. COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PERSONS THAT ARE THEN WE
HAVE WE HAVE I THOUGHT WE HAD
ONE. THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
MISTER GIBSON MOVED IT AND I
THOUGHT IT MISTER RIVAS SECONDED
IT SO. WE GOT IT. AB TWO FIVE
NINE SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO. BIGELOW
AYE BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN BRIAN IDEA
PUT ON COOPER. COOPER I DOLLY
DALI I DALY. DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES AYE GARCIA. AND SEE I
GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY YE LOW AYE LOW AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA
BURKE SILVA I'D ALMOST. RAMOS IT
OF US RIVAS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH I.
OKAY THAT MEASURE OF ALSO PASSES
BUT WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WHAT
WE'LL DO RIGHT NOW FOR SOME OF
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENT
HERE WILL RUN THROUGH THE-
ENTIRE RUN AND MAKE SURE WE'VE
GOTTEN EVERYONE'S VOTES RECORDED
OR IF THERE IS A FULL CHANGE
ANYONE CAN MAKE A CHANGE AT THAT
TIME. AND SECRETARY COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AGUIAR-CURRY.
YEAH BUT WHAT. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE RUBIO
RUBIO I. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT WILL KEEP THOUGHT THAT WILL
OPEN JUST FOR A FEW MORE MOMENTS
WHILE WE CONTINUE WITH THE REST
OF THE- BILLS.
FILE ITEM ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE LOW SANTIAGO. BIGELOW YOU
COULD SEE AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN
BRIAN BE A GOOD ONE. COOPER
DOLLY DALY DAVIES VOTE CHANGED
TO-ON SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE TO I
. DAVIES VOTE CHANGE CHANGE FROM
NOT VOTING TO AYE. GARCIA GIPSON
JONES SAWYER LACKEY NOT VOTING
LIKE YOU KNOW VOTING LOW. MATHIS
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS. RIVAS
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE SALAS SMITH. WE GET YEAH.
OKAY THAT MEASURE OUR PASSES OUT
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. OUR BROTHER
YEAH. WE'LL GO NOW TO ALLEN AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX AND WILL
DO THE SAME THING WILL RUN
THROUGH THE ROLE TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE GOT ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND IF THERE'S ANY VOTE CHANGES.
FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SIX SANTIAGO. BIGELOW
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN I IN THE
UPPER DRAW COOPER DOLLY DALY
DAVIES GARCIA GIPSON JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LOW MATHIS. YES I
DO. YES YES YES QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS RIVAS RUBIO SALAS SMITH
MCCALL OF THEM. AB TWO EIGHT
FOUR FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY. THE
UPPER DRAW. LACKEY LUCKY NOT
VOTING. RIVAS RIVAS I RUBIO.
THAT MEASURES OUT. WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES FOR A COUPLE OF THEM
MEMBERS- WILL KEEP IT OFTEN TELL
A LEVIN TWENTY. WHAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT YEAH HE WAS
REPLACEMENT.
THE BILL THAT. KNOW WHAT.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE SMITH. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE VOTE CHANGES
SMITH I DO NOT VOTING.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO STEP BACK WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR THE CHAIR HOPEFULLY HE'S
GONNA MAKE IT I HAVEN'T HEARD
BACK FROM AS YET BUT WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF. I JUST HEARD FROM
HE COMING BACK THE BE HERE
SHORTLY BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
GET- THE ROLE CALLED FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO WERE ABSENT
OSBORNE'S SECRETARY YOU MY
CALLING THE ROLE ON THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I BE
A COULD ONE BE APPROVED BY. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE LOW AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I. THE A PUT ON.
THE VALLAPUDUA I. THE BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO
FIVE NINE SIX AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D BE A GOOD ONE
THE OPRAH DRAW I. AND. THE BILL
IS OUT BUT WE'RE HOLDING THE
ROLE OPEN THE CHAIR WILL BE HERE
MOMENTARILY SO HE CAN ADD ON TO
THAT BILL. AND DID WE HAVE
EVERYBODY. ITEM THREE FOR MISTER
KALRA. TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR. OF WHAT THE MEN.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I'D BE
A PUT ON THE VALLAPUDUA I. THE
BILL HAS FOURTEEN AND IT IS OUT
. THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR- COMING
BACK I KNOW IT WAS HARD
EVERYONE'S RUNNING BETWEEN TWO
BUILDINGS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT A PROBLEM I'M NOT
A SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWO FIVE NINE SIX SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE HAS
TWENTY TO VOTE. EXCELLENT THE
BILL IS OUT. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS OF THE DAY WE STAND
ADJOURNED. A. B.